Speaker 1: We will next go to some mayor from
metro Detroit. Welcome to the program. I can
pronouncing that correctly.
Speaker 2: Uh. Simmer.
Speaker 1: Simmer. Okay. Apologies.
What's on your mind today, Sam?
Speaker 2: So I had a basic question. So I
know you've been on Fox News before. Would
you ever go back on and debate Tucker Carlson?
Speaker 1: Sure. Sure. I mean, here's the thing.
When people ask me, would you debate X, Y or Z
person, it's like, yeah, but about what? You know
what I mean? The thing about these debates is, and
in particularly on the Tucker show, like I would
do the Tucker thing just for the publicity because
it would be great publicity. But they set you up
to fail. They give you an absurdly limited amount
of time in general and then limit the amount of
time that you're able to speak you're given.
They can talk over of you because over you,
because of how the microphones are configured.
You're set up with extremely narrow and unfairly
framed questions like it's very difficult to show
up and come off looking like you really achieved
anything, you know? But for the publicity
and for the story, I assure I would do it.
But but the other question is about what, you
know, like, for example, what should U.S. policy
be on Ukraine, Russia? I'm not an expert in that
issue. You know, I follow the story and try to be
as informed as possible. But it's it's also about
like, what are we going to talk about? You know,
the Twitter files might be a more interesting
story. You know, we do much more media type
stories. And the Twitter files is a big media
story where it was billed as this bombshell and
it flopped. And so so would I debate him? Sure.
But it would have to be a topic that makes sense.
Speaker 2: Yeah. That that sounds
about. That's pretty. Yeah. Makes sense.
One other question. So I know you drive a Tesla
right now and you said you're not going to get
another one when you return your lease.
Speaker 1: That's right.
Speaker 2: What are you looking
at in as your next vehicle?
Speaker 1: I'm not really looking yet. I mean,
I'm going to stick with electric, but I think
it'll be based on what's available at the time.
And depending on when I get out of the lease,
you know, if an opportunity appears to get out of
the lease without having to pay 4500 bucks, which
is what I'd have to pay right now, I would do it
sooner, but I know that in 23 there's new vehicles
coming with longer ranges. And so I'll just
have to evaluate what's available at the time.
Speaker 2: I just know that lead times are pretty.
I work in automotive as I know that it's really,
really difficult to get a vehicle right now.
Speaker 1: That is also true. If I wait. If I
wait, they might say, well, it's going to be nine
months or longer before we can even get you the
car. So I don't honestly, I don't know yet.
Speaker 2: Okay. Well, that's our thanks
for answering the questions.
Speaker 1: All right, Sameer,
thank you very, very much for
the call. We're going to go
next to J.D. writes J.P. Mandel. J.D.
from Little Rock, you're on the air.
Speaker 6: And. David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can. You're a little low,
but I'll try to pump you up.
Speaker 6: I can speak up a little
bit. Hey, I just wanted to call in. I work
for a Calgary Power utility in Little Rock,
and we just got some interesting information
regarding the North Carolina substation sabotage.
Speaker 2: Okay. Um.
Speaker 6: We just
got a bulletin from the Electricity
Information Sharing and Analysis Center.
Um, apparently on December 3rd, there were three
ballistic attacks in the North Carolina and North
Carolina that have occurred at two substations.
Um, the attacks were targeting specific
aspects of the substation that would lead these,
this authority to believe that they were targeted
specifically to do that and
take these substations down.
Um, the attacks were all with the same kind of
caliber of weapons and they stand out because
they're different than what some of the past
attacks we've seen. Apparently six different
substations have been attacked as here in the
United States. And they kind of indicate that
those were more seeming to be lone wolf and this
kind of general vandalism while these attacks in
North Carolina seem more orchestrated.
Speaker 1: Okay. Well, we will we will
look into it. I have not been following the story
closely, but let me investigate. All right. Sure.
Speaker 6: Just just real quick that that
statement doesn't mean they have low confidence
that the motivations were motivated by a mix
of ideologies and extremist content. And the
links that they provide provide past articles
about links to neo-Nazi terrorism and white
supremacist terrorist plots targeting power grids.
Speaker 1: Okay. All right, J.D., thank you very
much for the call. No problem. Okay. So there
is an update, a very, very important update.